So welcome everybody.
Thanks very much for joining us today.
We are lucky to have two distinguished,
uh, coauthors of the, uh,
great recent book or coming out very
shortly, machine platform and crowd crowd.
Uh,
let me introduce Andy Mcafee and Erik
Brynjolfsson who are both distinguished
professors at the Sloan school at Mit
and Co directors of the Mit Initiative on
the digital economy.
I thought we'd start off by asking them
to tee up the thesis and the main themes
of their books for a few minutes.
I've got a few questions to ask about
both this book and their prior book,
the Second Machine Age,
and we'd love to open it up to all of you
both in the room and, and, uh, in, uh,
offices around the country.
So with that,
let me turn it over to you guys for a
quick overview of the book. Uh, the, uh,
we've known each other for some years
at a variety of, of different sessions.
And my favorite description of all the
wonderful things that can be said about
Andy and Eric. Eric is that the
FDA review called them the Pinup,
the pinup boys for the Davos crowd.
So I'm not sure if you can outdo that,
but think about what that says
about the rest of the Davos crowd. Just
ponder that for a sec. Jakks waiting on,
right. We would only be talking for
this session now just to get your,
get your expectations set properly.
So tell us a little bit about the book,
what you coming off
the second machine age,
which is a lot about the economic
transitions, the United States.
What's the next chapter in that story
that you wanted to tell with this book?
So coming off the last book, I think
we heard a lot of people saying, okay,
we get what you're saying,
that the world is changing.
There are these things
happening with technology, um,
and the economy is being effected.
What now?
What should we be doing
to take advantage in?
A little bit more about
how businesses can react.
And we saw a really three
big rebalancing is happening.
One of them was between mind and machine.
One of them was between
product and platform.
And the third one was breeding
the core and the crowd. First.
We thought we'd put all
those words in the title,
but then our names wouldn't
fit in 18 point type.
So we had to reduce the
number of words a little bit.
So the first one is what you
guys are all very familiar with,
this rebalancing between mind and
machine that machine's first off,
helping with a lot of humans make better
decisions, data driven decision making,
whether it's helping the Golden State
Warriors use analytics to understand that
three point shots are worth more than two
point shots and other things like that
or where we think you
need analytics for that.
Well apparently I wasn't well
understood until recently. Um,
and there may have been some more subtle
things that they pulled out as well. Um,
and of course before that it was the,
their neighbors, the Oakland, uh,
Oakland A's and the Boston Red Sox who
won a series of three world championships
between them. Um, and then, um,
it's coming to more and more businesses.
We've got about a three times increase
in the use of data driven decision
making.
By the way,
we've measured it across American
plants and even in our own history, uh,
tenure analytics,
we're using analytics to try to predict
who's going to get tenure at top
universities,
who is going to get prizes.
And then it turns out that it can help
predict the tenure committees in terms of
who does better performance. That just
the first part of that. More and more,
as you guys know, artificial intelligence
is making decisions on their own.
And I won't even go into all that because
you guys are very familiar with that.
The third, the second big rebalancing
is between products and platforms.
Five of the biggest companies by
market cap are platform companies. Uh,
Google alphabet here,
Facebook, Amazon, apple,
and Microsoft.
But it's a,
lots of smaller companies that
are coming up and growing,
sometimes almost out of nowhere
becoming multibillion dollar companies,
leveraging platforms and trying to
understand that trade off between products
and platforms and why those are so
much more powerful now. And thirdly,
between the core and the crowd.
Um, tapping into the, uh, millions,
actually billions of brains around the
planet is something that we can do now
because we have a global interconnected
digital network that allows people to
communicate that way in a way that they
couldn't have previously and not just to
access information but
to contribute to it.
So this helps us understand to make sense
of some of the weird things that are
happening in the economy,
the companies that are being destroyed,
new companies being created.
And there's some underlying economic
principles in each of these areas of
product, uh, of,
of a machine platform and crowd and laying
out the phenomena that are happening
with lots of case studies. And then
the economic principles. In each case,
it turns out there's some Nobel prize
winning economics that drive each of these
changes and that can help
us make sense of that.
So that was the basic strategy of
what we were trying to do with machine
platform and crowd. And, uh,
and we're hoping that we continue
to have this kind of dialogue.
We're looking forward to some questions
and comments from all of you to see what
the challenges are that you're facing,
the opportunities you're facing,
and see how well we can map them into
the framework that we've developed. And
yeah, what he said. First of all,
can't thank you for hosting us.
It's a pleasure and a real
privilege to come back.
We've learned a lot from
Google over the years.
It's always a pleasure to come
back and talk with you all.
I want to also thank Andrew
and your team@google.org uh,
Google dog over and is a supporter of our
inclusive innovation challenge back at
MIT where we're trying
to reward innovators and
entrepreneurs who are improving
economic prospects for average income
and below average income workers.
A lot of us in this room know that the
narrative these days is that technology's
killing jobs and it's not too far from
that narrative to therefore technologies
and bad thing. We think that's a
really harmful road to go down.
So we're trying to,
with the IIC,
we're trying to celebrate organizations
that are using technology to bring
economic opportunity.
We're really happy to have
google.org on board with us for that.
And then finally,
thank you all for showing up today.
I know you probably have a lot of things
to do. It's a pleasure to have you here.
I want to tell the origin
story of this book, uh,
because Eric and I wrote the second
machine age together and you know,
we kind of thought we were maybe thought
we were done writing books about this
period of crazy tech
progress that we were in.
And we noticed as soon as we finished
that book that people who run companies
kept on approaching us in the hallways,
honestly, of places like Davos.
And they kept on saying,
essentially, I believe your story.
Now what do I do?
And in some cases I got the impression
that there was actually some desperation
behind the question that they were asking.
The people were successful,
they were running large,
successful organizations.
And I started to get the
impression that they were at sea.
They were really floundering
or foundering, uh, about,
about what this technology
surge that they,
that they understood at some level the,
they didn't have a great way to think
about what this was going to do to their
business,
to their organization or their industry.
And that became kind of this
recurring conversation that we had.
And I found it profoundly interesting
because I didn't understand at first why
they were so lost. These were
smart, successful, experienced,
well educated executives and they felt
really just just deer in headlights with
what was coming at them.
And then as Eric and I did the work,
I realized that I should have been less
surprised by that because the mantra
about technology that I'm repeating to
myself these days is that tech progress
rewrites the business playbook.
And we're in one of those stages right
now where the two of us believe the
playbook for how you run a successful
business is being substantially rewritten
by the kinds of new
technologies that we're seeing.
The last time I think this happened
was just about a century ago when
manufacturing went from being steam
powered to being electric powered.
And there was a naive
way to think about that,
which was take out the big steam
engine in the basement of the factory.
We replaced it with a big electric
motor in the basement of the factory.
And a lot of companies did that. That
was kind of a no brainer. Um, people who,
what we learned from business history
is that the companies and leaders and
business leaders who grew
up in the era of Steve,
it's not that they are unwilling
to invest in electricity.
It's not that they thought electricity
sucked. It's that honestly they could not,
their minds did not admit the possibility
of an overhead crane or a conveyor
belt or an assembly line.
These things did not make sense.
If you had a factory powered by belts
and shafts and pulleys and steam in the
basement.
This was just crazy talk.
And you can go back and read
the literature from those
early decades of the 20th
century.
And there are these vicious debates about
should we put a motor on every machine
in the factory?
Like that was nutty for decades,
even though it's completely
obvious in retrospect.
So the homework that Eric
and I had for ourselves, um,
wants to think of these days.
What are the equivalents of overhead
cranes and assembly lines and conveyor
belts that forward thinking
companies are on top of.
And that ones who are trapped in previous
mindsets and previous ways of thinking
are just not going to see. And that
led to our three part answer. We,
I see a lot of companies
underestimating the power of
machines.
A lot of companies underestimating the
power of platforms and a lot of companies
not doing a great job of tapping
into the crowd out there.
Yeah.
So if a company like ours,
we feel very much in the middle
of a lot of these phenomena. They,
you start your blog with example of
Alphago with deep mind, the platform.
Obviously we have a number of
different things that a platform like
characteristics, android and a
lot of others. And even on crowd,
you can argue that Google search is the
greatest man machine collaboration in
history as people will use our systems
and and improve the systems through their,
their clicks. Right. So what
would be your advice for Google?
What do you think we're getting wrong?
What do you think we should
be doing differently?
And I see we're just about out of time.
Thank you all for coming.
You do it. A lot of things
right. And so I think that it,
one of the risks is that in a way
you may become too successful.
And I think one of the things that we
don't talk that much about in the book,
but I think we're going to see is
that as we get more of a winner take,
most economy and very successful companies
are able to use these technologies to
dominate market after market.
Cause they understand those three
platforms and other companies are just
beginning to get them.
Then there can be a backlash.
And I'm in a push back against that. And
one of the questions is, you know, um,
what kind of economy
are we in going forward?
Is it one where there's a monopoly
capitalism or is it, what is,
we've talked about in the book,
got more of a shipper Tyrian creative
destruction where there's always the risk
of a, of one platform being displaced
by another. But understanding this, uh,
the economics are a little bit different
in a world where there are very strong
network effects or even
two sided network effects.
And there were some big scale economies
and very rapid technological change and
that's something that I know
that you very much on top of him,
he was understanding and those
kinds of dynamics. And uh,
and relatedly,
something we touched on the last book,
is this winner take all or
where did it take most dynamic?
It doesn't just apply to companies,
they can apply to individuals as well.
So we're seeing growing inequality on
a lot of different dimensions in it.
It's great as Andy mentioned
that google.org is helping to,
um,
identify business models that can
create more broadly shared prosperity as
mother counterweight against a
world where all of the other, uh,
wealth and perhaps political
power gets more concentrated.
I can't,
I think this is a great question.
I want to answer not
specifically about Google.
What about companies full of smart people
and at the risk of flattering people
in this room and watching us.
Okay.
There are a lot of smart
people working at Google.
The single biggest failure mode that I've
observed related to the content of the
book when it, when I talk to
audiences are very smart people,
is that smart people tend to have an
exaggerated version of a failure mode that
everybody has,
which is to be too fond and too
confident and too reliant on their own
intuition, judgment,
experience, intelligence,
and they are there. They're very often
guilty of some of these cognitive
biases that Eric mentioned,
Nobel prizes that Danny Conoman got a
Nobel prize for figuring out the failure
mode among really smart people is to
trust themselves too much and one of the
points we make, the broad point we make
in the first section of the book is look,
your intuition is awesome.
It is demonstrably buggy and failure
written and it's got all kinds of really
powerful,
pretty bad news failure modes.
The fact that your Iq is well above the
average does not insulate you from that
and in some ways it can make that worse.
Overconfidence bias tends to be worse
among really smart people to the point we
make in the first section of the book
is to hammer that point home and make
people feel bad about themselves.
But then to say, look,
we have these awesome colleagues now
called machines that have very different
failure modes than people do. They're not
inconsistent. They're not overconfident,
but they're really stupid about the world.
There's a wonderful
concept from linguistics.
It's called the intuition
of the native speaker. Um,
I can recognize a faulty,
I'm grammatically fall to English
sentence just in the blink of an eye
immediately.
And people who don't speak English
as a first language can't do that.
The reason I bring that up, we have
native speaker intuition about the world,
or even with all the work you guys are
doing, our machines don't have that yet.
So one of the broad points we try to make
is let's bring together the strengths
of p of minds and machines.
We, if we do that correctly,
I think we can cancel out each other's
failure modes. The big homework,
especially for smart people is to become
more aware of the failure modes of
humanity and more willing
to question yourself. Second
guessed yourself, use data,
use machines to buttress the fee,
the mistakes that are wet ware has.
And there are lessons from the other two
sections of the book as well. I mean,
you guys know joy's law that no
matter what company you work for,
most of the smart people in the
world don't work for your company.
And it's probably even true for Google.
That may be the edge case.
And um,
so it,
it's great that we were just last night
with Anthony Goldbloom co founder of
Kaggle and it's great to
see Google tapping into the
power of the crowd and all
of those smart PFLs or
they're not contributing and
the AI initiatives that are
allowing people to contribute in different
ways and use a tensorflow and other
things to,
to uh,
tap into that crowd knowledge
and on platforms. I mean, yes,
Google has not just one,
but multiple great platforms,
but as we described in the book,
those are constantly evolving.
As the technology changes. There's
always a risk of them being displaced.
And of course there's new ones rising
up as you go from a, as a Syndra pick,
I said a mobile first to an AI first
world, that kind of transition, you know,
Microsoft kind of bottle that going
from desktops to uh, to mobile.
And there's these constant risk. So, um,
because of the rapid change that
that we were just talking about,
you can't sit back and feel like,
okay, we've got the problem solved.
We just had to, we can just
relax. I think the lessons,
all three sections of the
book, um, apply to Google.
Let's talk a little bit about timescale.
We get very excited about this.
We feel it. It's the
ocean we swim in. And yet,
and to your example about electrification,
I,
it took 50 years to disseminate the
effects of electrification through society
and Broadway.
If you look at something like the cell
phone was conceived of in 1947 demoed in
1973 sold in 83 and it really wasn't until
the turn of century or later until it
became widely adopted.
So are we overestimating how quickly
all this is coming along or do you think
this is right around the corner?
I think especially the geekier set is
overestimating how quickly things are
going to happen,
how quickly the cars are going to drive
themselves and we talked to AI in our
homes and everything happens
in the drones deliver stuff.
I think we are overestimating that.
However,
I do think that a lot of people are
underestimating that and there and the
communities that Eric and I tried
to be part of this is an extreme.
There's a super active debate about how
soon as x going to happen and a lot of
people rely on those historical examples
that you just brought up and say, look,
this is a decades long process.
My favorite counter to that
is how old was Facebook?
2000 fourish Facebook has 1.9
billion users around the world,
like close to a third of humanity has
adopted this technology in the space of 15
years.
We have never ever seen this before.
So in a world that is interconnected with
pretty powerful devices and where the
cloud is available on demand more,
almost everywhere and we're really
powerful tools are being put up into the
cloud. The timescales can be
quicker than we're used to
and I would make a distinction
between those two examples you gave.
I think Andy's exactly
right that the technology,
I think it's evolving a lot faster
than than the cell phone did,
but what does it seem to be moving a
lot faster is our ability to adapt the
business process change and
that's what held back electricity,
electricity was the technology was there
for a good several decades before the
factory's reinvented their
business processes and
reinvented their organizations
and there are some technologies
that can be adopted. You know,
without a whole lot of business processes
change like a consumer facing product
like Facebook,
but a lot of the ones that really have
big societal changes are going to require
a lot more adjustment
in self driving cars.
It's going to be not just a matter
of having them navigate the vehicles.
There's a whole set of
laws, ethics customers
keep you up at night
thinking about barriers,
all that ad at Moore's law,
types of speed.
One of the big reasons we really like
geological time, they go backwards.
Hopefully that we can,
we can move it
the dial a little bit in that I think if
people understand how to take advantage
of these technologies, they understand
the process change necessary,
we can make it happen a little bit faster.
Um,
once we give them a bit of a playbook
about what works and what does more,
and it's true that the progress is really
going to be piecemeal, so nationwide,
fully autonomous cars that
that might be a bit off.
We were talking to every node Coachella
yesterday and he brought up that one
company that he's aware of is trying
to just think about automating driving
trucks between what was a Dallas,
Phoenix and Dallas and La. He said,
let's just do that. There's $1 billion of
commerce has, that's $1 billion market.
Just driving trucks back and
forth between those two cities.
Can we get regulatory approval for the
states on the route and can we w w that's
one route.
We know how to map that pretty easily so
that can happen pretty quickly and part
of it was not do all the little side
street onto the highway and then tech some
person to show up and drive it.
It's going to take a while to completely
rewire and put sensors all over the
electric grid and get the efficiencies
that we, that we're hoping for with that.
At the same time,
the thought experiment that I run is how
much work would it be for some kind of
industrial facility to
slap sensors on everything,
give it to tensor flow and
maybe get the kind of um,
15 ish percent step change improvement
that the Google data centers saw when
they turned over operations to a
cousin of the Alphago Technology.
So they're are going to be,
they're going to be relatively quick,
big wins happening all over the economy,
I think.
Now let's talk a little bit about
the social implications of that.
Something that you covered in depth in
second machine age but continues to be
very relevant when you're talking
about driverless cars immediately.
There's concern about employment
transition and displacement.
Uh, they're sort of,
the standard response is more
more training and perhaps
either earned income tax
credit or a universal basic income.
Your training has been kind
of a mixed success rate.
They're not a lot of great case studies
there. People trying to do new things, uh,
online training and the like
interested in your thoughts on that.
And we're generally on the balance between
our need for growing productivity as
our workforce ages and potential impacts
on social structures and implement.
There's no silver bullet.
Um, and I think there are a lot of
people, you know, it was wonderful.
You'd be looking far enough ahead.
It's going to be very hard
for education to keep up.
But I think where we are right now in
2017 and as far as I can come in the next
five, 10 more years of training
and education is probably the,
at the top of my list. And I think most,
most economists list, not mine. Okay.
So Andy can end.
It can weigh in on that,
but there's different kinds
of training education.
So some of them give very specific
tasks. You know what? What's a bashing?
Throwing a couple of doing it you Udacity,
you know you can learn some skills quite
rapidly. Add a great deal of value.
Tom Kahleel described something that
Darpa did call it the education dominance
program that in 90 or
120 days when people,
people some very concrete skills
that massively increased their value,
the more lasting skills are going to be
the ones around interpersonal skills,
creativity, teamwork, persuasion,
some of the softer skills that
machines aren't very good at.
I don't think our schools are doing a
very good job of teaching those are or
worst yet. I think many of we're actually
crushing, crushing them, crushing them,
and making them less salient.
So if how many of us feel like we had
some of the love of learning crushed on of
us by your education? Just honestly
show hands, way up in the air.
Please look around the
room. Yeah, this is a crime.
This is a crime because I think most
kids actually, they love being, you know,
to put a pile of blocks in
front of a three year old,
the first thing they'll do
is stop building something
or, or crayons, kit kids,
humans love creating. And if we could
nurture that and let that flourish,
that is what machines are not very good.
Uh,
playing and interacting with other people.
Teamwork.
That's what machines aren't very good at.
So it's not just a matter of
spending more and educational,
but I don't think that would hurt.
I think it would help,
but it's a matter of more
fundamentally reinventing education.
There are so many tasks in our
economy still that only humans can do.
And that's the way it's
going to be for a while.
So I'm not ready to
write off human skills.
I think we should invest and make people
ready to do all those different kinds
of human tasks in healthcare, education,
childcare, um, creative works.
And, and that's going to be
the way that we, I think we,
one of the ways we create more shared
prosperity. But you may disagree.
I agree with everything you just said.
Here's why I disagree with um,
with an education reform first
approach to fixing things.
My thought experiment is let's say there
is a pot of money available and you
could do only one thing with it.
And I have three kind of
prime candidates in my mind.
Number one is reform education and let's
say it's going to cost something didn't,
what number was that? What the, the amount
of money, you know, what number was that?
That was number one. Not In,
not in descending order. Okay.
A is perform education.
Option B is to figure out
why entrepreneurship in
America has been on a long
slow,
steady decline and reverse that option
c is to bring our infrastructure up from
a grade of d plus two,
maybe a solid B.
I would actually take either
option B or c over option A.
I'm not saying that I'm right and I'm not
saying it's a no brainer, but I would,
I would love to solve either
of those latter two problems.
First I fall back on something
that Larry Summers says, um,
in his inimitable fashion, whenever
somebody brings up education, he said,
education reform is kind of a dodge,
and unless we grow the economy faster,
we're not going to be doing
a lot for jobs and wages.
That's a very strong way to say it.
But to grow the economy faster,
I would love to figure out
why entrepreneurship is
sucking in America and I
would love to fix our infrastructure,
which is just the biggest
no brainer out there.
But the good news is we don't have
to choose just, it's one of those,
I think that there is no
silver bullet. As I said, it's,
we should be doing all of these
things simultaneously and some of them
government can help with a lot of these
we can do without having government
involvement and maybe, you know, depending
on which way the winds are blowing,
it may be that we have to take more
responsibility as individuals or as
organizations to step out some up on
some of these other dimensions. Yeah,
I completely agree with that.
Without a reservation this time.
And one of the really encouraging things,
sorry,
one of the really encouraging things in
education as the rise of these really
alternative ways to get really powerful
skills to get credentials and designal
signal how good
you are at stuff.
That's a case where the government has
been lagging in many cases and in fact
because student loans are only
given two accredited institutions,
in some ways the government is
impeding progress in these areas.
Now I don't think I'm a frothing
at the mouth libertarian,
but I would like to see
that situation change.
So let me ask one more question then
open it up to questions from all of you.
We don't have mics around the room,
so please just shout out the
question will repeat it back.
So we catch that on the
mic and for people remotely
a desk SAS question two
is your way to get it?
Yes. So I was going to say, so
Andrew has the dory available,
which is running a constant number of
questions and actually voting on those
questions. So then you have
a retinal implant. Exactly.
Solid tensorflow with lumps.
Questions will surface the top, but,
but let me step back before
we open it up to everybody.
And that's about the global
implications of this.
I mean there've been some have
argued that the growing use of robots
industrialization is blocking paths to
development of tradition that available
for evolving countries.
During that,
some old glue argues that every time you
employ a robot you don't employ three
to five people. Uh, what,
what's your take on that?
How do you see this playing out globally?
Well, it's such in the global
one first. Those are Andy and I,
along with Michael Spence,
one of our friendly Nobel prize winning
colleagues wrote an article about some
of the implications for globalization.
And,
and that was a couple of years ago in
foreign affairs and we talked about this
challenge that in many ways,
although technology has been one
of the best things that happens,
it happened to have open.
As you probably know,
there are a lot fewer people in poverty
now than there were 20 years ago.
And the tr a lot of the
trends are very good.
If you look a little
further into the future,
there's some storm clouds and in
particular countries that are right now,
depending on manufacturing have to be
that engine to lift them out of poverty
are very much in the bullseye
of a lot of the automation.
You go visit new China and you see
thousands of people working side by side
doing very routine simple tasks,
tasks that a lot of you
guys could probably write
up some code to get in about
20 minutes to do those tasks.
And you know,
those workers were able to compete very
effectively against American or German
or Swiss workers by lower wages.
But you don't want to be competing on
the basis of wages against a robot.
And so that means that that middleclass
that's been created in a lot of
developing countries is not going to
have to compete with robots that can work
for $4 $2 $1 an hour equivalent.
And that's not a good place to be.
They need to leap frog to a situation
where they're doing more of that creative
and interpersonal work. You
know, for better or worse,
there's not that many manufacturing
workers in American factors anymore.
I mean it's less than 10% of
the workforce you go into.
Most factories it's kind of lights out.
So we are in some ways less going to be
less effected by that kind of automation
of factory work.
Then those developing countries,
and it may make it harder for
them to make that transition.
Some countries like China, they have a
very sophisticated tech economy as well,
so they're got a good chunk of the people
on the other side of that curve. Uh,
other countries like Vietnam,
the Philippines, I'm going
to have a harder time
metro position.
The way I look at your question,
there are two unmistakable big,
big global trends related to the things
that we're talking about. One is,
is betterment has improvement
in the human condition.
We've had the largest declines in dire
poverty that we've ever seen around the
world.
We've had the biggest increases in human
health in recent decades that we've
ever seen around the world. Do you all
know if the site, our world and data,
this is, this is my favorite
side, cause you walk away,
just happy after you go look
at almost any aspect of it.
So the first one is that the
world almost without exception,
is getting better in the areas that
we care about. That's the first trend.
The second one is concentration.
And when it gets to this notion that we
are doing more and more manufacturing
and a smaller and smaller
geographic footprint,
a smaller and smaller
employment footprint,
a smaller and smaller number of companies,
footprint,
wealth is getting more concentrated,
income is getting more concentrated.
It almost doesn't matter where you look.
This trend is really pronounced. Now,
I don't know if those two trends are
going to continue to interact kind of
happily,
or if there's kind of a clash of the
titans that's coming when these costs
declines.
Implicit in Moore's law,
meet rising wages in Bangladesh
and China and places like that,
those two trends could run kind
of headlong into each other.
I don't know that's
what's going to happen,
but that's something to keep our eyes on.
Okay.
So let's open it up to the room and is
ready if we're going to have questions.
But first,
so the question
on one hand we see increasing returns to
scale and perhaps more concentration of
wealth. Uh, certainly we have seen that
and the other hand we see this decline in
productivity and are those
two not a client productivity,
let me be more precise,
a slower rate of political creativity,
growth. It's still growing. Um,
and are these possibly connected?
And I think there are some
people who are making that case,
Joe Stiglitz and others that there's
this in Grice of a rentier economy,
people a red seeking.
I don't see it quite yet.
It's something I'd like to keep
my eyes open and take a look at.
I think that some of the areas
where you're seeing these, uh,
increasing returns to scale actually
some of the more dynamic parts of the
economy.
So I would look elsewhere.
If you look at the part where
there's been less entrepreneurship,
where there are fewer a young new firms,
they're not in those parts of the
economy where we're seeing, uh,
the network effects and so forth.
So I would look to other things.
There's issues around
occupational licensing,
there's just the aging of the workforce.
And I see everyone here is pretty young
but, but sadly when people get older,
they don't get to be as entrepreneurial
as there are old people working in
America.
I know that's weird for you all and most
of them are not starting companies. Um,
and so, so that's part of it. Um, it is,
it is obviously a little bit of a mystery.
The people who've studied this
like John Hall to Ang and other,
they're not quite sure what's
going on there in terms of that,
that effect in terms of the other
drivers or productivity growth,
why I think we see, we'd be
talking about these wonders things.
The other thing we have to bear in mind
is most of them haven't really hit the
marketplace yet. You know,
Andy and I rode in a,
in a self driving car the first book
and, and again, you know more recently,
which is a lot of fun, but they're not
a whole lot of them out there on the,
on the highways or most of the other
amazing technologies. We're excited,
I think folks in Silicon Valley excited
cause we can see what's in the pipeline.
But in terms of measurable effects on
Productivity Right now we are really
harvesting more what happened in
the 1990s in terms of technology.
I mean back in 1997,
the same Silicon Valley folks
who are excited about ecommerce,
but did it really make a dent
on traditional retailing?
Not until 2017 and you know,
the past couple of weeks you've
been reading a lot about that.
So there's a pretty significant lag
between when you see these wondrous
technologies and when they're going to
show up in the productivity statistics.
And um, that I think is probably more of
the explanation behind some of those two
trends.
You describe it.
We have a rockstar colleague back in
MIT named John Van Reenan who dove into
exactly the question that you're asking
and he documented that in industry after
industry there are the superstar firms
that are appearing a small number of them.
They're sucking up a lot of the revenue,
lots and lots of the profits in industry
after industry, not just in high tech.
And he says that might explain some
of the trends that you brought up.
So the interesting thought experiment,
is Amazon good or bad for
overall retail productivity?
And the initial, my initial answer
is going to be awesome for it. Well,
if all the other companies in retail
are seeing slowly eroding revenue and
they're not laying off
people in droves yet,
then overall productivity for that
sector could actually be a slowing down,
are declining because of Amazon's
sucking all the energy up into one really
concentrated place.
So the data,
we got to dive deeper in it since
a fundamentally important question.
And there are a couple of
different promising lines
of, of uh, of research and,
or to just touch on briefly that
the Amazon one reminds me of is,
is this a measurement issue as well?
That our GDP statistics are
just horrifically bad at
capturing the value of free
goods like
Google, basically a lot of others. You
all shrink GDP. Did you realize that?
Stop it when you take Britannica. I
turned into Wikipedia. GDP goes down.
Wow.
But welfare,
it goes up and Amazon is providing
a lot more product variety choice,
timeliness. Um, and,
and none of those shorts in
the GDP statistics either.
So we have a bit of a mismatch.
You go back to Simon Kuznets
who invented the GDP,
one of the great inventions of the 20th
century, uh, Paul Samuelson said, um,
one of the first things he said was,
please,
please do not use this as a measure of
welfare. It is a measure of production.
It's not a measure of
how well we're doing,
but of course the first thing everybody
started doing was assuming GDP equals
welfare. And, and that's just
mathematically wrong. Yeah.
We should cut over to the Bhutanese
model of gross national happiness.
If you go too far,
I mean I think one of the problems is
that the nice thing about GDP is you can
measure it to like nine
significant digits and it's very,
very satisfying to be able to
each quarter and you can decompose
it for other things.
It went up to quite low. Sorry,
it was 2.4% and that and you know,
gross national happiness,
you know,
I'd be lucky if they get the first
significant digit, right? Yeah.
You,
you're coming about the aging population
and productivity reminds me of a most
astonishing statistic.
I've seen perhaps this year that within
three decades if taking out Africa and
population growth there for the rest
of the world within three decades,
the average age of humans on the planet
earth will be 60 years old. Wow. Wow.
That is a dramatic change in the ratio
of productive people in the workforce
unless they useful the time and workforce
changes dramatically and requires an
awful lot more productivity to help adjust
and there that there may
be a good thing to know.
Rod Brooks and others have
really emphasized this,
that let's bring on the robots as fast
as we can so they can help take care of
us at our old age.
Yep.
So Andrew,
question from the Dory.
All right, so we have a question from
Miguel who's in New York and he asks,
given your research and the
rates of technological change,
what are your thoughts on
universal basic income?
Reeducating everyone should be legal,
but at this can take years or not happen
given the emergence and multiple pilots,
do you think of ubi as
a potential solution?
Uh,
absolutely.
People should be researching ubi.
I think the experiments that are happening
in Finland are really interesting.
I think what y Combinator is doing is
pretty interesting. By all means, let,
let's do the research.
Let me tell you why I'm skeptical
about a universal basic income and it's
extremely straight forward.
A UBI in its most classic form,
provides no direct incentive,
no direct encouragement to work.
And as Eric and I have gone on with
the work, I've become a, with our work,
I become a fanatic about work,
about the value of the importance
of something like a job,
not for some kind of old
fashioned Protestant work
ethic reason I don't think.
But because the evidence is overwhelming
that when work leaves a community,
bad things happen. Not
good things. There's,
the research is just overwhelming on this.
You see marriages fall apart,
you see couples not getting married,
you see kids not being
raised in nuclear homes.
You can think so what you see
crime going up. No, that's pretty,
that's pretty unambiguous. So what, um,
a lot of us know that an Deaton and Ann
caissons and Angus Angus Deaton and Ann
Case,
uh,
highlight of this crazy phenomenon that
we were unaware of until recently that,
uh, death rates, mortality
rates among white,
middle aged Americans are actually
increasing instead of decreasing.
And the reason they're
increasing is because of what
they call deaths of despair,
suicide, chronic liver disease,
alcoholism and drug overdoses.
I can't tell a happy story about that.
Those vessels,
the spirit really strongly concentrated
in exactly the kinds of communities and
demographics that are
least likely to be working.
So I think about that and I think what,
which of those social problems will
be fixed by a magical check from the
government showing up every month?
And my answer and that thought
experiment is basically none.
And our friend Bob Putnam really helped
educate us about the these issues. But,
but I want to underscore the first
thing. And he said, you know,
we're all for experiments and let's,
let's try some different things because
we can sit here in our chairs and,
and say, Hey, this is what
we think motivates people.
But the truth is there haven't been
that many real tests of some of these
theories. I think we'd
done in different ways. Uh,
Norway has been faculty six
successful with the oil wealth,
giving people a longer vacation.
There's a lot of childcare taken care
of people and maintaining a pretty high
level of satisfaction.
Other oil rich countries have had not
been as successful in navigating that
level of wealth.
So I think that there's clearly some,
some devil's in the details in terms
of how you structure things and how you
help people that can lead to
very different kinds of outcomes.
The other thing to say on this point,
this is a really fundamental question.
Another reasons I'm not a fan of the UBI
is because it might be a solution in a
w n a post work world and a world where
we just don't need a lot of human labor.
There was nothing in the evidence that
says we're heading into that world yet.
We've added net jobs in America
month by month four I believe,
75 months straight,
and you can go graph the number of hours
of labor required to generate America's
economic output.
It has gone up in lock step with GDP ever
since the end of the great recession.
So when you're looking at the trend lines,
you don't see any plateauing or leveling
off. You don't see the end of work.
I'll become a lot more
excited about a ubi when,
when the amount of labor hours needed
to generate economic output starts to
level off. So America has
high rates of labor mobility.
Is that something that we should be
encouraging or discouraging earning high
rates, relatively speaking.
Well actually, yeah.
One of the concerns is it actually that
number has been falling quite a bit,
but go ahead.
So is it a good thing to encourage people
to go with a job sooner or does that
risk hollowing out the communities
that Andy's talking about?
It's that it's better than trying to will
those communities back into existence
if the,
if that's not going to work.
Absolutely.
I think that one of the most misguided
policies is trying to target lander
geography rather than people.
What we want to do is help the people
and if we can get them to match jobs to
jobs better matched to work better.
Mobility is one of our best
tools and America, as you said,
has historically been one of the most
mobile societies and it's becoming more
and more stagnated, ossified, and that
is exactly what we want to lean against,
seen as some of our policies I
think have a little backyard a bit.
We have big subsidies for home ownership,
which sounds like a good thing,
but it can lock people in to homes.
And there are a lot of other barriers in
terms of land use regulation that have
made it harder for people to move.
And maybe there's some
cultural things as well as,
as communities have become more
uh, uh, balkanized and stratify.
So, um, you know, if, if a,
a group of people can find better work
somewhere else, I say, hey, great, let's,
let's find a way to make it easy
for them to find that magic.
And there are lots of places in
America that have shortage of labor.
There are other places that
have surplus, um, you know,
whether it's go west young
man or whatever the is,
it's been something that's been part of
the DNA of America to be dynamic in that
way. It's weird that morbility just
moving around the country is again,
on the decline in America.
It's,
I think it's really hard to see
when you sit in either Cambridge,
Massachusetts or silicon valley,
but almost any measure of
business dynamism that you
would care about is heading
the wrong direction in America
and has been for awhile.
How many of the people in this
room were born in Silicon Valley?
And just kind of curious. Okay.
Three, five hands. Yeah. Yeah.
So, uh, so that you know, at that, and
it's great that not just silicon valley,
but America has been a magnet for
talent and that's part of the,
I wouldn't call it a secret sauce
cause it's not really a secret that's,
you know, attracts the best and the
brightest from around the world.
And one of the things that really saddens
me just to be very like specific to my
area is when we get these brilliant Grad
students that come from other countries,
China,
India or wherever,
and then they're finished their phd and
they want to stay and the government
says, no, you have to go back.
We don't want you anymore.
And they're like, no, no,
we want to stay. And they were like, okay,
go, go, go back. And like, well, okay,
I guess I have a cousin working in
Bangalore. I guess I'll go work with,
with him or her. And uh, you know,
eventually they're not even gonna want
to come here anymore and we'll have to
beg them. And I think that's, uh, that's
bad for the war for the United States.
And I think maybe bad for the world
because you're not getting the optimal
allocation of talent to where it
can paid value. And I'll speak,
you know,
for the home team for America,
this Koffka esque nightmare that we've
created that we put in the way of some of
the world's most talented and ambitious
people who want to come to this country
and build their lives and careers. I, that
that's what our enemies would do to us.
It makes no sense to me.
The majority of the people working in
silicon valley who were actually born
outside the United States.
So we're working to prove that a
question in front and then in back,
ah,
got Mike's Technology improves and well,
and let me back to the developing world.
For a second.
You mentioned how automation may be
more dangerous in manufacturing reliant
countries and Indiana state of course,
I wanted your take on what strategies
does countries should try and develop to
anticipate that's,
and specifically if you think services
can be an interesting path for growth at
an enduro when the trade of services,
uh,
I think of a passage of the
trade in goods these days.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a super tough question because the
path to prosperity or the path to being
a middle class country was pretty clear
in the 20th century. And to uh, to,
to speak a little bit bluntly,
you went through a sweatshop phase.
He went through a phase of
heavy industrialization,
a decent portion of the population
worked in manufacturing, uh,
in factories in sweatshops.
And then over time you developed a
more robust economy, more diverse one,
a civil institutions came along with that.
They became pretty healthy countries.
We saw that playbook and the 20th century,
Danny Roderick is a really good economist
who is documented that that playbook
is looking less and less likely in the
21st century. Mainly because of, you know,
we believe,
um,
robots and to a lesser extent the
fact that we have tons of capacity in
countries like America and China
and Germany. So your question,
which I'm really stalling on is
what's the new path to prosperity?
And the reason I'm stalling is it's,
I don't think it's clear at all.
I don't know about the template for
the 24th century path to prosperity.
That doesn't include either a phase of
industrialization or a or a, um, uh,
a resource endowment. Aye. Aye.
What you say sounds right to me,
it has to do with human capital and
services that can be delivered over a
distance. I don't know the
shining example of that yet,
for better or worse, I think,
I think, uh, unfortunate.
I think it has to be a playbook that
more and more similar to what developed
countries have because we could be
coming globally and interconnected,
which means you have to have an educated
workforce that can deliver some kind of
value that's greater than,
than that other people are delivering.
And getting people up to speed on that.
It's hard.
There are some digital tools that
can speed that process a bit.
And so that's going to be part of it.
There may be options in,
in services that can help a little bit.
Personal services tend to be localized
so then they are somewhat insulated from,
from globalization. But
it's a, it's a tough,
it's a tough question and one that
we should worry about.
The clearest example I think
is the Indian high tech sector,
which is a fairly small industry
in a very, very big country.
So I don't know how well that scales,
but my playbook for the 21st
century will be kind of, you know,
bathe your country in bandwidth,
get cheap devices to the people,
help point them the way toward these,
these amazing educational resources
online and entrepreneurial is we'll find
that human capital and put it to work.
That's easy to say and really hard to do.
Another example is a little bit like
that is that burgeoning o two o sector in
places like China online to offline where
these technologies have allowed lots
of entrepreneurs to create
many, many services, uh,
new kinds of products and services that
wouldn't have been possible before.
It's you have a uh, an explosion
of small scale entrepreneurship.
All right,
so we're running up on time or two
questions and back but so many speed round
unless you both through your questions
out there and I'll let you and we'll
answer it quickly.
Good.
Okay.
I was wondering when you said that
there are a lot of jobs being created,
are the autumn in manual labor or are the,
the print can have jobs and what do you
think the average person is going to do
in 30 or 50 years or whenever every
manual labor already is fully out and made
it like,
do you have any thoughts or ideas on that?
I'll try to do that when super quickly.
The engine of job creation in America
has downshifted from classic middle class
jobs to lower middle class jobs.
They tend to be service sector jobs.
They tend to be jobs that involve
doing work in the physical world.
So home health aide, gardener,
short order cook kinds of things.
The robots can't do those jobs yet.
Your question is what does,
what does the world or world of work
look like in 30 or 50 years of continued
tech progress? I want to
be clear. I have no idea.
Let me just depend, uh,
to Andrew's answer. Um,
there's a big chunk of growth at one end,
there's been kind of polarization.
There's also been some very high end
jobs who's been created the middle that's
been hollowed out the worst.
So there's high end jobs like
the ones people in this room,
a lot of people who have
creative technical skills can
command much higher wages.
There's probably no better time in human
history to be somebody with those kinds
of skills or talent or luck.
And there's no worst time to be somebody
with just routine middle Scott middle
class, uh, skills that are
increasingly automated.
Okay.
Okay. Uh, one last question. The very
back, I promise. I'm sorry, please.
Um,
I wanted to ask about like labor and
capital and how this is affecting,
so do you think this trend plays into
that where like corporate profits are at
an all time high and the weight share
of the economy has been dropping and do
you think that like there's this u shaped
curve in labor where like low skill
jobs are safe,
very high school jobs are safe and middle
skill jobs are kind of taking the fall
or do you think it's like all of labor
as a whole is going to take a fall
compared to like the capital
of the corporate profits?
The recent trend is fairly
clear and you pointed it out.
It's increasing share of GDP,
going to capital and a
decreasing share going to labor.
For a lot of the postwar
decades we thought that
capitalism was going to lend to
lead to greater quality of have
in common or financial outcomes.
I don't believe that anymore. I think
that the trend, like I said earlier,
is toward concentration.
There were things we can do about that.
It's called redistribution.
It's called tax and transfer.
It's called wage subsidy.
This is not an insolvable problem at
all and I'm less bothered about that
problem and some other people. Um,
but, but refusing to address it is,
is the cardinal mistake.
And looking to the future,
we have to really be careful about just
extrapolating what happened the past.
A lot of what happened the past couple
of decades was sort of the first wave of
computerization, uh, automating
routine work, repetitive work,
looking forward to what
artificial intelligence can do.
There are a lot of other types of tasks.
So I want to mention manual tasks. Um,
some very creative work last night be
node was talking about, uh, cardiologists,
oncologists and radiologists as Josh
at me and very highly paid jobs, right?
So we may see different than going on.
I think the only sure thing is that the
pace of change is increasing and we need
to have a lot more flexibility.
We need to be able to sense and respond
and be active in how we do that and not
just sit back passively and thinking,
well,
I hope it works out for us because we
think there's a lot of things that we can
do as individuals,
as organizations,
as a society to help shape the path
we're going towards and we do this right.
This is going to be the best thing
that's ever happened to humanity.
We're going to have a lot more wealth,
a lot less need for work.
We're going to have people,
but there's absolutely no guarantee that
we will hit on all of those dimensions.
It's quite possible we can have a much
more dystopian scenario where there's a
tremendous concentration of wealth and
other outcomes that we aren't as happy
with, but ultimately it's
not the choice of technology.
It's going to be the our choices that
determine that and the reason we wrote
these books was to help provide a little
bit of guidance on what some of our
options are and then we have to apply
our values and see if we want to go in
that direction. This is the headline to
end on, and this is awesome. Overall,
human prosperity is about to increase
even faster than it's been doing.
We're heading into a different chapter.
If we blow the distribution,
the sharing of that
prosperity, shame on us. Andy,
Eric Machine Platform, crowd cloud
crowd at your guide to the 21st century.
Thank you very much,
Ken.
Thanks a lot.